incertidumbre de un lado al otro de la
frontera México estadounidense a menos
de una semana de la eliminación del
título 42 sé que lo quieren retirar el
11 pero no se sabe si es verdad o es
mentira los comentarios Igual yo voy
para adelante yo me voy a quedarme aquí
porque yo he pasado he sufrido mucho me
han robado he pasado de todo yo voy para
adelante la normativa fue implantada por
el expresidente Donald Trump para
devolver en caliente a los migrantes con
la excusa de la emergencia sanitaria
ahora Washington prevé la llegada masiva
de migrantes a partir del jueves y
advierte de consecuencias
la frontera no está abierta y no estará
con posterioridad al 11 de mayo
en un entorno posterior al título 42
utilizaremos nuestras autoridades de
expulsión acelerada en virtud del título
8 del código de Estados Unidos eso nos
permite expulsar a individuos muy
rápidamente
con la nueva Norma Estados Unidos
advirtió que los migrantes que no puedan
demostrar que son Víctimas de
persecución o torturan sus naciones de
origen serán expulsados y podrían
sancionarlos con hasta cinco años de
prohibición de ingreso al territorio
estadounidense las organizaciones de
Derechos Humanos denuncian que la
búsqueda de asilo es un derecho legal y
sigue siendo atacado por Estados Unidos
lo que está reemplazando el título 42 es
la prohibición de tránsito también
conocida como la prohibición de asilo
habrá dos centros de procesamiento uno
en Guatemala y otro en Colombia donde la
gente tendrá que ir si quiere pedir
asilo en Estados Unidos
Mientras tanto México reconoció un flujo
importante de personas en tránsito por
su territorio y llama a los migrantes a
informarse sobre las vías legales y a no
caer en engaños